hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I am Geo
and I'm Bart and uh did you know
that the person that manages the rocks
business portfolio and Enterprise you
know who that person is his mom no his
wife no
it's Danny Garcia
what the [ __ ] are
[ __ ] are you about right now do you know
who the [ __ ] Danny Garcia is I don't
know but he sounds like a cousin of mine
Danny Garcia is his college sweetheart
uh they were married
The Rock they got divorced wait Denny's
a man or a woman a woman
you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] I've never
met a female Danny before but okay got
it you need to meet more people so his
ex-wife manages all his ex-wife now
manage manages the movies he's making
out with other hefas
that is awesome I always admire couples
that um I mean we have a couple friends
like this that you know have had kids or
were married with or just have had a
life with somebody they break up and
then they continue to either work
together or co-parent and everything is
just copacetic yeah so what I wanted to
ask you no [ __ ] no [ __ ] everybody I'm
burning it all down don't [ __ ] me over
what are you even talking about the
conclusion [ __ ]
go what I was gonna say you [ __ ]
theater curtain
don't act like you don't want to rub me
fine everyone underneath you
um underneath me underneath the [ __ ]
theater curtains wait are you wearing
double corduroy
I thought he was talking about damn
Euros read between the lines recorded
[ __ ] yeah
um what I was gonna say is
let's say we put ourselves in this
scenario okay we're divorced
would you pitch me
to get me on a date with someone else oh
come on you know because you manage me
now because Danny Garcia is the Rocks
manager so even though romantically
they're not like this she wants the Rock
to continue to crush and succeed
how do you do that with me easy so
you're talking to me I'm a [ __ ]
professional bro okay I'm right here
yeah
well Margot Robbie's right here you
messed something up Mario Robbie's right
here you forgot how do you sell me
tomorrow you forgot something because
did we break up on a good note or a bat
like did you did you [ __ ] me over like
did you [ __ ] lie steal and cheat we
or did we just go you know what
it's not working now yeah that way that
way oh yeah why would it I'm I'm a chair
baby are you [ __ ] yeah am I no what okay
cut it out you know it's super mature
sell me to the world
um well what world are we talking about
making a movie like this is why you
should cast my client to a hottie with
the body sell me oh for a date yeah oh
my God that's funny okay I'm gonna be
like you know what Marco
um uh is she showing an interest in you
or doesn't even matter I mean everyone
shows interest in me okay fine Margo so
okay this is gonna be such a weird
conversation but I just I have to put it
out there because if you don't date Bart
you're really going to be missing let's
put it this way let's say I'm gonna go
right and I'm like okay I know you guys
used to have a past
um we started doing these movies
together
um I think I'm liking them do I have a
blessing 100 okay
um so what do you think about it
um okay so it was unfortunate that it
just didn't work out between us how come
we didn't work out
um Why didn't it work out
did I just make it up Oh I thought you
were gonna give me more like you keep
interrupting okay
um we were just you know it was it was
awesome when we were younger we wanted
the exact same things like you know we
were both I was really supporting him in
his career and I wanted to be the
stay-at-home mom and I just wanted to
have a ton of kids but then the more
that you know we got into business
together and the more we started working
together I just realized that I wanted
different things than what he wanted
um so it really had nothing to do with
our personalities or anything it just
you know like I just we just lost that
love that in love feeling for each other
and we just our life paths went in
different ways like he's such an
intelligent human being he was so loyal
and he was so supportive
um yeah like if if you know in a
different life if I didn't want what I
wanted and he didn't want what he wanted
we would have probably stayed together
is he good at eating your vagina no no
no it wasn't that good but I mean he's a
fast learner maybe like you could teach
him a few things like I just don't
really care for it so like he's so open
to anything like like you talked to him
about it and he's so down and try it is
he good at having sex not really but I
think like but you're supposed to sell
me to her I don't want to lie so wait do
you give it a lie yeah whoa Daddy
probably lies she's gonna judge me like
she's gonna be looking at me and going
we're building an empire in a new way
now you think Danny how is she gonna
make me money you think Daddy doesn't
lie to every single person about the
rock of course if it if it involves some
sort of like Financial exchange this is
Hollywood baby everything's connected
yeah yeah yeah but no one gives a [ __ ]
about that yeah
how am I getting a piece here this is
called networking their Roi comes
[ __ ] three degrees I know but if you
know how to do business the right way
you're not gonna lie about [ __ ] because
that's just not gonna last you got to be
up front so you gotta be honest Danny is
telling the truth about the rock all the
time uh she's she's making it as honest
as she possibly can across you're just
not gonna last him I'm not a liar you're
Danny Garcia okay I'm [ __ ] uh Men's
Health uh-huh
don't you do it it's the Rock on
steroids
um I don't even know what steroids are
you just told me you're not gonna lie
what the [ __ ] is going on okay is a rock
on servers that's your question you're a
[ __ ] is that your question is that
your question right that's a question
yeah I would want to know okay why are
you so fascinated with if he's natural
or not what what are you trying to get
to the bottom of
I'm not making it complicated but I just
need to know where you're trying to go
you don't need to know I'm Men's Health
okay yeah and I'm looking out for my
client what do you want to know I wonder
if he's on steroids why because I might
give them some storage sponsorships
there's no such thing what do you mean
how do you know you don't know anything
I know I know a little bit about a lot
and that's [ __ ] so unless we talk
about his movie or his stuff that's
coming up you don't even know about
anything oh this is the manager I like
now rewind okay okay is Bart good at sex
uh not really but what the [ __ ] this
person just changed again
how can you go about lying about
steroids I didn't lie yeah you did I did
not yes I did switch the conversation to
something that mattered which is I need
to get my client to talk about his
[ __ ] project I don't give a [ __ ]
about what Men's Health wants my [ __ ]
needs to [ __ ] go first that energy
needs to be applied to Bart at having
sex go
uh well are you paying me extra like so
if you paid me a percentage for every
[ __ ] HotBox Men's Health is Bart good
at sex
okay well how what does that matter I'm
doing the interview you don't know this
is a [ __ ] weird conversation you do
not need to know about my clients sexual
Chris Hemsworth if he's good at sex I
ask [ __ ] Robert Downey Jr if he's
good I ask everybody this is a weird
thing to your goddamn manager this is
[ __ ] weird it's part of that success
no we need to talk about the [ __ ]
rock in Moana okay so that's what he's
promoting that's what we're talking I
can already tell if we actually got
divorced you'd be horrible business
partner
uh to get you laid probably because I'm
gonna tell the truth no in general
because Danny is doing a good job and
you would do a bad job with me
okay well then because I just asked you
a couple questions and you already you
already failed and miserable okay let's
switch it then okay switch it same thing
for you all right is Joe good at sex
really good the best we'll make sure the
best well
um but you don't have to lie that's the
thing no you're telling the truth that's
just what's not fair look at me
you see what you see right yeah she did
a good job I can't even last 60 seconds
with her I know but now you're telling
the truth no you know what I mean like
you don't have to lie what do you mean
what's something that you have to lie
about uh everything
that'll be [ __ ] serious okay I'm bar
Kwan Geo's manager who the [ __ ] are you
uh Bart coin juice manager well so are
we trying to go back to the dating we're
trying to anything I'm have Geo's best
interest in mind even though I'm not
married to her anymore that's the
relationship this is Hollywood
everything matters controversial like uh
The Rock right because you put me on the
spot about steroid usage doesn't matter
this is Hollywood baby what can you stop
saying that that's what Hollywood means
it's the Wild Wild West anything goes
yeah yeah yeah uh but you don't have
anything controversial is my point like
I don't know what to bring up that like
it's [ __ ] controversial it doesn't
matter just hit me with it I'm bar I
manage Geo what the [ __ ] do you want
L'Oreal
[Music]
does g
's that test on animals no she hates it
she's pro-animal wants animals to be
cruelty free and cruelty free
environments yeah but we test on animals
so how's she gonna do with us
just gonna [ __ ] rat your ass up I
already [ __ ] up
money what do you mean I'm in the
process of making money you just [ __ ]
up you should have already known that
L'Oreal tests on their [ __ ] they do
I'm I mean it doesn't say cruelty free
on the back give it to me go you already
[ __ ] no no give it to me the only
[ __ ] the one time I gave you six
tries one more time go
see I need her off the [ __ ] Squad
Give me another one okay who am I uh
anybody I am barquan and I manage Geo
um I the GEOS Empire
I work for uh Nike okay hey what's up
Nike nice to meet you yeah give me a
call pairs of free shoes if you can but
go ahead what do you want
um
does uh does Geo
uh what what are Geo's views on you know
our uh factories in China she loves them
she loves how you keep her expenses low
provide jobs for people that need them
and they're able to contribute to the
global market
you're the worst why you're [ __ ] you
suck how do I suck you're like what are
you pitching you pitched nothing you're
Nike you're pitching at me you think the
rock pitches the people or people pitch
the rock yeah so this is what a good
manager does all right no too late I
already won already got the thing no you
didn't get the thing this is what a good
manager does okay because I used to
[ __ ] manage you [ __ ] idiot and
look how far we got a good
hey hey hey hey no I didn't manage you
guys go ahead I wish I would have uh you
guys would have been way further but
um so a good manager always
besides the [ __ ] dollar amount right
always knows what their [ __ ] client
wants and how to get that there without
like this [ __ ] Nike back and forth
conversation it's just going hey
we don't give a [ __ ] what you do on the
side this is what we want what do you
want let's make it work oh cause flip it
around then you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I'm
Nike hey Geo Bart's manager yeah what do
you think about our factories over there
and overseas huh uh
what what does that matter
we're here that doesn't matter so
where's Hollywood baby
we got it we're talking in circles until
we arrive at a point okay yeah this
Hollywood you've been you know the drill
you've had 2 000 meetings that don't
matter putting about those factors over
there yeah it doesn't matter I don't
give a [ __ ] about this message what I
give a [ __ ] about right now is we get
what we want we give you what you want
what do you want what you want what do
you want for your client um I want my
client to make 10 million dollars just
purely wearing uh uh Nike in every
single thing that he does okay
um he also is gonna start this new
project and I want you guys to back it
up okay
um I don't know all right cool let me
think I'm talking all right so yeah this
is Hollywood baby they want 10 million
dollars yeah we do have that new product
that's coming out of uh to bed yeah but
it's all child labor no that's why we're
gonna make all that money okay we'll
make it back okay yeah so we got
um a whole new Factor we just opened in
Tibet
um
really cheap child labor over there
don't tell anybody that's why you signed
the NDA before he came into this room
are you cool with that if you are put on
10 million I'll give you 11 million
dollars
damn it
let me talk to my client okay go ahead
hey Bart
uh so they do a lot of child labor [ __ ]
how do you feel about that
11 million dollars though I'm not Bart
I'm Nike no you're part no I went to you
okay cool because this is we're gonna
have uh what the [ __ ] do you want we're
[ __ ] divorce ready [ __ ] calling
hit him up blood on my phone yeah so so
11 million dollars but they do child
labor [ __ ]
will Define child
uh taika oh dude he needs a job for sure
11 million let's do it okay wait wait no
no we got to think about this again okay
um so if Ford were to ever get out that
this is what you got paid for to work
with this company that represents this
thing I don't think it's a good look
dude why why why are you wasting my time
so you're in this company to help make
me money and now you're bothering me I'm
not bothering you I'm literally on a
date with Margot Robbie and then you're
[ __ ] give me this [ __ ] I don't
want to [ __ ] talk to this I don't
want to hear this [ __ ] ever again I
never want to mad at you you suck I'm
literally on a date we're ordering
sourdough bread and we're about to have
a good old time and you're [ __ ]
bugging me I told you we're over okay
we're [ __ ] over it take a [ __ ]
hint yeah and you're [ __ ] bugging me
with this [ __ ] Nike million dollar
child labor [ __ ] okay so I'm gonna
just say we're not gonna do it okay I
need my money all right you I need my
money I'll get you money I need my money
you need your [ __ ] 10.50 I'll talk to
you later you better handle the deal
handle the deal I don't want kids
involved see you later okay fine fine
okay so now I need to speak to your
[ __ ] I'm Nike now okay hey Nike
um shove it up your ass we already got
10 movies lined up we're gonna make over
a hundred million dollars we don't want
it we don't support child labor The Rock
would never stand for any of that [ __ ]
thank you so much for your time and [ __ ]
you very much
then we just burned a bridge I did I
forgot hey Under Armor Adidas Reebok
yeah so uh Danny or Geo is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] say no to her please Adidas uh
whatever you did to yay pull that on Geo
please
I'm not going public with it it's
[ __ ] Hollywood baby anything and
everything goes hey uh so far we have to
talk about some [ __ ] I told you I'm with
[ __ ] Margo Rod what the [ __ ] do you
want yeah um so I I I I'm just gonna
quit I quit
yeah
um quick
this is so weird
see that's why I really respect them
because I think it's hard I think it's
really hard to like be romantically
involved like I couldn't imagine myself
being in their shoes maybe I don't have
the maturity but for them to be
romantically involved I think I could
for sure and then so because you're
building an empire of course and then
now you're building an empire in a
different way but then now you have uh
different lovers so
why can't you of course you can because
I think Danny's husband
is her brother no no it's also in the
Rock I mean the Rock brother is in the
Rocks Empire too and I think they do
something together oh you know what
Danny's husband I think is the head
honcho for zoa the energy drink that all
makes fun of the ecosystem it all makes
sense though
really well yeah so like your immediate
circle
it's not like when we were kids right
like when you're in high school and you
have access to so many different people
like you tend to find your significant
other
usually where you spend your most most
of your time
right so for them to be like
romantically involved but be do business
it all makes sense
because they're in each other's close
proxy mix
so she met her husband at a [ __ ]
energy drink taste testing no I don't
mean I don't know how they met I don't
know their [ __ ] biography but I'm
just saying it's not odd to me it's not
weird
but when you think about relationships
isn't that weird
[Music]
um
um if you're emotional and immature yeah
I think it's weird like let's say we
break up right yeah and then your
husband but if we break up like your
husband works for JK
don't I always go hey little [ __ ]
[ __ ] well I think I think if I knew you
were that way then I wouldn't allow that
that wouldn't happen but I don't but
don't I write your paychecks so I kind
of like why would I would if we didn't
have a mature with I could stretch your
finger but if we didn't have a mature
relationship I don't want anything to do
with you now because I know it's going
to be drama the entire time and I don't
want drama ever is it maturity based on
the number of zeros on the paycheck no
I'd rather be broke
I'd rather I guess not
I suck at business because if Danny were
to manage anyone else
why do you talk about Danny like you
know her and [ __ ] you don't know
anything about it I know a lot about her
Danny Garcia oh everyone knows her all
right she makes a lot of money with the
rock yeah because the rock got a big old
freight train of an Empire moving
forward right he got the tequila he got
the energy drink he got the Under Armor
shoes that all the UFC fighters must
wear
we got the movies
you got the a whole enchilada
and she can go off into her own thing
and make nothing or you know
but you're also making it sound like
this is all easy like she's working
really hard for all of these deals
you know for her to be at the level that
she's at it's not because she's The
Rock's ex-wife it's because she's
[ __ ] good at her job if she wasn't
good at her job she would have been
doing some other [ __ ] she might be a
good job it might be sucking out wifing
I mean maybe or maybe she's not maybe
they just weren't compatible but I think
I could do it for sure
you think you're a better wife or
anything a better business partner um I
think I'm a better wife
for sure man I don't think I'm built for
business my heart aches too much I don't
think I built for business too to be
honest yeah my heart aches way too much
I got better husband actually I'm not a
pretty good husband either what the [ __ ]
are you talking about of course you're a
good husband really I don't buy you
[ __ ] flowers for no reason well I
don't want flowers I [ __ ] throw
petals all over the floor and [ __ ] yeah
I don't want any of that I'm gonna try
to clog up our vacuum cleaner I don't
want that I want you to [ __ ] let me
sleep in get taika ready for bed take
[ __ ] Mia out when it's really cold I
did do all that um hug me up randomly
for no reason that's me yeah send me a
[ __ ] picture every time you get a
haircut like that's the [ __ ] I want
really you like you want to get a
haircut no I like when you send me a
picture when you get a haircut really
why because it's CUNY because it's just
like you're so like you like it so much
and it's something you want to share
with me and I think that's so cute I
think you're a wonderful husband what
are you talking about you stupid ass oh
thank you
um but yeah I think you could do it too
I we we have the ability to want to be
[ __ ] mature like we're super mature
people I think so
um
so yeah super mature and we can we
understand how to separate personal
emotion with business like it's just
they're two separate things
that's tough I honestly can I tell you
the truth I only have to do it
really I think if you and I built some
sort of empire together
um but if we ended like on a good
handshake and but we both reached the
same conclusion where we're like hey you
know what we're really good at business
but we're just not good at lovers I
don't think I could do that are you
serious yeah I think but like you came
up with it too you know what I mean like
I don't think I could do
shut up are you kidding me no why I
think I'm more of a um
I need to like clean my palate I'm a
pallet cleaner
but okay so maybe we're both not as
mature no not at all you like drinking
Coke after you brush your teeth
I mean I'm like brushing my teeth after
I drink Coke that's different
I don't think it's the same thing
for me I think like
um
I love you so much
all right I'm trying to emphasize that's
the part that I'm trying to emphasize
okay I love you so much
and everything that we've built has been
built on the business and the love at
the same time
that I think if we took the Love Away
the business would feel
way different
and
um my interest in enthusiasm in the
business would have a huge void okay
sorry are you done
you know yeah
um so if your business was making a
hundred million dollars a year you're
only focusing on
um they check in with you they go hey
these are some reports we generated this
is what we're thinking we're going to
launch for 2023 do you sign off on this
that's literally your role
that's all you do everyone else is
running everything else for you all
they're doing is giving you this
portfolio to check in on just brand
Integrity hey are we kind of hitting the
what you what you envisioned for
yourself
you would still feel like oh you know if
we I built this out of love with Geo
shut the [ __ ] up that's not even true
is this like [ __ ] like three stock
paper who chose this [ __ ] Geo did huh
[ __ ] no way so at that point in
business you would do that that doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense because you're
not even involved in the business
anymore I'd rather move to Montana and
raise goats
that doesn't make any [ __ ] because
you're already gone from the business
you got the [ __ ] bigwigs just taking
it over no I'm very I'm just submitting
reports quarters when I build a business
out of passion and emotion
when the emotion dies
um I feel my passion goes along with it
yeah but you're an artist that's right
yeah but now the biz that's what I'm
trying to emphasize that the business
group passed you and passed anything you
ever wanted
yeah like you can now go in [ __ ] so
it will collapse even harder than ever
but it won't collapse because it doesn't
matter that you're in it or not then I'm
out I would collapse harder than ever
why mm-hmm
you gave me the chills dude why'd I give
you chills I just don't get it my mind
doesn't understand it I just need a
sometimes I just need a fresh start I
just need a break you know a break is
fine I get a break but that's why I'm
also so I'm trying to emphasize the one
the 100 million dollar a month [ __ ]
money I'm also trying to emphasize that
we both reach this conclusion at the
same time so there is no heartbreak it's
just over a period of time we both just
realized that we grew apart and it
there's no hard feelings there's no like
I broke my heart or like you're not sad
about it if anything you're like
relieved that now you're letting me live
my life and now you can go live your
life and fulfill whatever it is that you
want to fulfill so there's no like
unbroken-hearted I love you so much if
the company is big enough
where we're both so removed from each
other which we will be and it's a giant
system like we're just [ __ ] two
people at Google yes yeah probably
that's what I'm saying but if we're both
like
board members
and we gotta be in the same meeting room
still but you're acting like someone
that's a broken heart
yeah but I'm saying there is no broken
heart because we both arrived at this
conclusion together there's no such
thing
there's always going to be broken hearts
so you're saying there's not there is oh
maybe broken heart that you failed at a
relationship yeah that's what I'm
talking about there's always going to be
broken hearts but not because that's the
one that got away that's different but
Hearts have been broken what the [ __ ]
are you doing right now what are you
doing
I don't know if you're [ __ ] with me
I'm not I'm just saying when Hearts have
been broken yeah
it changes the whole
I mean it's sad because it's an end of a
like a friendship is that what is that
what you're holding on to that
friendship part of it because
when I do something with you right
as much as I wanna
it's like this let's say I want to go to
[ __ ] JK let's do Straight kids
example because I was a part of it and a
huge chunk of it but you didn't do it I
mean you did it with me but you didn't
build it I mean you did build it with me
too but you built it with Joe it was you
and Joe exactly so if I were to leave
there you're fine so if Joe leaves I
don't know if I'll continue to do no
because you're Brokenhearted yeah if if
Joe backstabbed me well that's different
that's not what happened that's not what
I'm doing okay there is no backstabbing
I'm trying to emphasize here okay let's
say Joe [ __ ] loves June B right loves
that Hawaii [ __ ] that he's doing right
now he's like you know what I want to do
more of this yeah I'd be like go do more
of that Jake is done
oh
[ __ ] because half of it is built on the
passion
the other half is built on my love for
Joe right so if Joe's not there the
passion itself isn't strong enough to
continue I'd rather go
sniperuski and then I'll nurture the
passion because I still have a passion
for making the funny Funnies and also
movies and stuff like that but I'll do
that on my own on a smaller scale and
it's more controlled and then I'll have
I'll uh Sprout New Life
you know
yeah you're a [ __ ] artist too gross
its own little new plant yeah somewhere
else you know yeah I'm completely
different
for me I'm like oh it's just business
baby it's Hollywood no it's like let's
say you and I gotta classic car Want to
Build Together
and then that's different because that's
so intimate it's just you and I but when
that's why I'm emphasizing again the 100
million dollar company yeah I don't know
because it's so much bigger now there's
board members I don't know if I care
about money that much if I especially no
no it's not the money that I'm no but
even if I have that so especially if I
have money like let's say my lifestyle
let's say my the rest of my lifestyle
let's say I already have [ __ ] money
because we make 100 million dollars
right let's say I have like I don't know
20 30 50 million in my bank account for
sure I'm like take it away I'll [ __ ]
go raise goats in Montana
because I really don't need this company
I'm literally doing it like if I don't
need this company and I'm literally
doing it for you but now a relationship
is over
then
yeah yeah like why would I need to
continue you know what I'm saying yeah
that's so interesting why tell me how
you view it
uh so for me it'd be what are the goals
right so one of my goals would probably
be like let's say
that I really love this job
right I really love I really loved you
and I really loved building it with you
but now you and I have come to the
decision to split up because we just
want different things in life we fell
out of love we're just different people
than from one we met right so we're good
nobody did anyone dirty we're good
um but now my new goal is now like I
[ __ ] love this job and like I'm
passionate about it and I would still
like let's say I'm your manager if I'm
passionate about managing and I and I
know you and like I'm passionate about
managing you then I would still manage
you no problem
yeah I wouldn't care because like we're
fine we ended like in a in a good way I
have zero feelings now like once it's
done I'm done like we move on it's a
different chapter now like I could
totally do it
damn I think maybe girls are just way
better at managing emotions like that no
I mean it's just a person maybe it's
just a person personality thing I don't
know but for sure I could do it um and
and and I would even feel like super
honored to do it because now I know you
on some crazy intimate level where I'm
gonna be like I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] no
one else can ever [ __ ] outdo me
because they're never gonna have the
same Insight that I have
so I'm that's probably why you're badass
yeah so I'm like not only am I like did
we end cool but like I'm [ __ ] good at
what I do and I have the upper hand
that I believe and that I respect I
respect that you have that confidence
because you do have that Insight but um
I don't know if that's something I can
do
hey I'm really cold-hearted because even
that's why even like you know if like
when I meet chicks through the homies
when the homies break up with the chick
unless I built my own relationship with
the check I just I unfollow them too
yeah I'm like no need I only know you
yeah yeah through this
this that you guys are done I'm done bam
you know yeah yeah
so that just because I don't need to
know you anymore yeah I mean you never
even knew them
but we were acquainted sizing yay but
you didn't know them yeah I get it
that's the same way I am yeah
it's like you're not adding anything to
my life yeah
you only came into this circle because
of my
with my homie you're out of the circle
yeah yeah we're pretty closed off
we're super closed off people but
um no I could totally do it like for
sure do it
maybe uh maybe it's a traumatic thing
that I can do that or I can like shut
things off and then yeah like just like
later yeah I don't know if I could do it
I think maybe because of my upbringing
I've had so many Fresh Starts it's just
easier to just have a fresh start
fresh start new life that was like a
past life okay
no residue from the old life just 100
forward you know I mean that's a clean
slate and it's a nice I'm a smart Clean
Slate person I think
yeah I think for me it's just what the
goal is what's the goal because like the
job that you have right the job yeah you
can get like let's say you're a manager
you can get the same job anywhere else
it doesn't have to be at this
okay
it doesn't have to be it could be
[ __ ] c a a w m e whatever it doesn't
have to be at the barquan Empire it
both are like the residue and uh but it
but I'm like if we have a really good
working relationship and nothing Shady
happened
and we both agree that we can make it we
can still push forward yeah and we both
want the the same thing in terms of
business why would I start anywhere else
it's so hard to click with people we
know this
it's so hard to click with people on a
relationship level it's so hard to click
with people on a friendship level
business level working relationship like
it's hard like once you find your people
[ __ ] hold on to these [ __ ]
that's true I can see that so yeah I
just don't know if I could do it but I
see that that's [ __ ] crazy yeah maybe
I'm just a [ __ ] cold-hearted [ __ ] or
I can just know how to like look and
super separate it but yeah I would have
no problem I don't know if I could
answer this way in my 20s maybe in my
20s would be like with a child
what let's say you start something with
the baby with taika yeah and then you
know
um passes away for some reason oh my God
I think he would be able to continue
depends on what it meant to this child
so like if it was their dream then I
have to carry it on I have to pursue it
that's CUNY um but if it's something
that they didn't care about then it ends
yeah
oh that was a good one
yeah but if they didn't care about it oh
my God that would just break my heart
because this is a different circumstance
now they were taken from me I see you
know where it's it's not like he's going
like if it if the scenario now is I
start something with taika
um but then he hates my guts and he
hates working with me and it's just
we're just fighting too much I'd be like
as much as I love that position I'm
gonna say hey you know what for the sake
of our relationship and for the sake of
my relationship with you I'm just gonna
step back as much as I love this I
prefer to have my kid and a good
relationship with my son than whatever
this this thing is yeah that I would I
would step away
yeah
because that's more important yeah yeah
that makes sense yeah but again that
that's keeping the goal in mind like
what is the goal you know whereas in our
scenario my goal is I [ __ ] love what
I do and I'm good at what I do so I'm
gonna stick with what I know
and what I love doing but if I didn't
love it and I was only doing it for you
and we break up then yeah I'm bouncing
what the [ __ ] I need to be around for
like I I was only doing it because it
was an hour us type thing but I like
yeah there's no reason for me to be
there let's see
yeah that's crazy because a lot of like
workplaces you know there's a lot of
like the interpersonal drama where
people do get together we're like you
like the office right like Pam and Jim
they do get together then it's like the
whispers are on the office like what do
they have to say if they turn out really
really good then you do endear like
maybe a couple years of early on [ __ ]
talking but then now people are
supportive of you it's just crazy it's
hard to like navigate the um
the Dynamics of life it is but it's
still doable is it of course
of course it's doable why wouldn't it be
doable like it just becomes a thing
like in the beginning it'll be awkward
because we're putting in our own
insecurities and shortcomings to how we
assume they're feeling about each other
so then we start going oh that must be
awkward oh my god did you hear how that
tone was but for them they might be
completely cool but after a while and if
the more you do it did I just click with
myself what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that but yeah the more that this
relationship is super stable with new
with like either new employees or new
staff or just the the regular stuff they
just see that it works um and if it
works then it works you know
because I I even felt that uh just to
navigating the Dynamics of relationships
kind of difficult even um starting in
like Junior High in high school
what do you mean like when I would get a
new girlfriend
and then I don't know maybe I was just
really insecure at the time but like
let's say me and my girlfriend are
holding hands walking down High School
like I was always like
I would always I was scared if anyone
was like oh what's going on over there
you know I'd be like uh don't say
anything why why were you scared I don't
know it just felt so like like just look
somewhere else what the [ __ ] yeah what
is that or just just assume that it's
normal like just don't make it a thing
what is this what is that like get out
of here yeah but why why get out of here
I don't know I didn't like that energy
the energy of what of people going like
look you're holding who's that
girlfriend of yours and how did you
perceive that what does that mean
I don't know just felt like like why is
all this attention on me
but you so you perceived it as like
they're gonna judge you
like you just don't like it like you've
had a failed relationship and now
they're looking at this new one or maybe
they they saw Bart as The Branding of
single and that part's not single
anymore oh I don't know it's just like a
different like I know they view me
differently now because I now have a
plus one yeah they're looking at me like
that
what I don't even understand I've never
had that thing no so we had a boyfriend
you're like hey it's my new boyfriend
and everyone's like oh cool and you're
like oh hell yeah I can't wait to bring
them into the high school
um yeah so for me it was more of like
man I hope my friends see what I see and
like them because that's the last thing
I would want that's [ __ ] mature oh
yeah that was the only thing so I was
always so scared in high school I didn't
have that I just felt for some reason I
just felt so like um
I just felt people were gonna go like
ooh let's Bart is a girlfriend again who
cares yeah you do I was [ __ ] I don't
know I was insecure about something oh
interesting no for me it was more like
[ __ ] manic like so I know that in my
girl group we have a certain Dynamic
like this trick is this way this chick
does this this chick does it like we all
have our rules right in our group
um and as soon as one of us gets a
boyfriend we know that dynamic's
different now right because we're gonna
have her part-time or if she does bring
in the do we have to speak a certain way
like it doesn't change too much but it
definitely changes its Dynamic so what I
was always afraid of was to bring in my
guy it [ __ ] up the dynamic and I'm like
[ __ ] this so sucks so what I would do is
if I would ever get in a relationship
and this is the funny part is
um I would just disappear like I would
be like hey boyfriend time okay I'm off
with my boyfriend try to integrate not
yet no
um and then and then like if I tried to
integrate and it would be weird I'm like
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] it all up yes I would
rather do all Dynamic though yeah I
would just feel like okay then I just
gotta either separate it or like
integrate it once in a while
um yeah
that's how your group was cool
because it was just a full integration
absorption hey you're already in and I
was like oh [ __ ] this is what
yeah yeah
that was really cool maybe we're just
super judgy or maybe I was just super
insecure yeah but I I do feel like at
the end of the day all humans are just
dogs at a dog park trying to figure it
out and figure out the Dynamics it's
absolutely because it's difficult
absolutely because you're like someone
might be insecure or someone might be
like seemingly aggressive but then you
realize it's coming out of fear yeah so
but you're you're treating them through
the aggression so it's inaccurately uh
dealing with that situation yeah and
it's just everything is just like so
much to manage you know yeah the older I
become though the more I realize that
the more uh or the the more I can be
genuinely myself
um
that it makes it easier do you have a
more of it like take it or leave it
mentality yeah now I do that's getting
stressed whereas before it was like
um I mean I kind of always had that a
little bit uh but I don't know I think
maybe like in my mid-20s 30s I was more
like oh [ __ ] am I doing something wrong
let me change that because I feel like
I'm doing something wrong what was the
part of you that you were maybe more
hidden about
that you're like [ __ ] I hope they don't
I mean I hope that they do
accept it when I was in my 20s and 30s
but now you're like you know what this
is just who I am I don't care if you
like it or not so when I was first
growing up
um because I was a middle child and I
was already labeled the black sheep and
the [ __ ] up and all the bad stuff I was
already like this with everyone right so
I was like if you want to be my friend
cool if not cool right so that's why
like my circles were always really small
um but they were really tight
but then when I move into more college
and in that era it was more like wait is
this like wait I don't have a lot of
friends am I supposed to have more
friends like what am I doing wrong like
am I coming off too harsh am I a little
too am I too Crest am I too honest am I
too upfront am I too intimidating so
like all the things that I love about
myself now that I used to love about
myself back in the day that I didn't
realize I love about myself in that
middle awkward spot I was like [ __ ]
maybe I'm too much for people maybe I
need to tone it down I feel like I'm
making people what are those things you
loved about yourself
um that I would just speak my mind be
super honest be super bold with my
opinion
um like it like I just knew what my
position was with things
you know and and like I would just say
[ __ ] and it's like it's like I'm always
open to conversation but it was like
sometimes it was too much for people to
handle and they were like what the [ __ ]
or I would just be misunderstood and I'm
like damn if you knew me you know I
don't mean it like that you know
um and for sure maybe my presentation
was all [ __ ] up
but uh the older I've gotten and the
more attacked I've learned throughout
the years too I found that sweet spot
for myself at least where I'm going no I
actually like being bold and I like
being outspoken and I like speaking my
mind and I like giving my opinion but
balancing that with
um you know understanding when to like
speak or listen or like say things a
little bit softer you know you can
always be honest but the the vehicle in
which you deliver it can be a little bit
softer
uh whereas in the my 20s I'm like [ __ ] I
just need to tone all of it down just
keep it to yourself be a little bit more
like like don't make people feel
intimidated by you or whatever so I
would just kind of just hide a lot of
[ __ ] and just like even though I knew
things I was just like oh yeah yeah we
can try that when I'm going like this is
[ __ ] dumb like it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense but yeah let's just let's
just try and I just I was [ __ ] dying
inside I'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on that was actually like me with uh
being a funny guy
uh holding it back yeah I think I think
I've always been a funny guy but then
once you get into that like almost like
gain hard world you know like [ __ ]
hard I'm a [ __ ] Thug like that yeah
um I kind of put away the jokes and the
goofing around and stuff yeah
um but I've always been like that I've
always been the most humorous Class
Clown and I just like [ __ ] around and
I put that away for a long time like
almost all of my high school and I
almost forgot that I liked being funny
yeah until
um
even when I met Joe I don't think I was
my true funny self really yeah so I
think that's when I met Joe and we
started doing our characters I think um
I I think that's why they went so
extreme because it was a uh me finally
letting loose yeah and then letting it
all come out so we were just like we
don't give a [ __ ] like we're just gonna
put on whatever outfits that we think
are funny that looks ridiculous and just
go crazy and JK helped bring that part
back out and it's something that I'm
very proud of now that I can be funny
you know and I like having a good time
yes CUNY yeah but it took it took a long
time it was something that was just put
away not even realized that that was a
part of me that I liked yeah I feel that
not the funny part but I feel that
um just kind of making yourself into
something that you're not so that you
don't ruffle feathers you know yeah or
you don't cause any waves anymore you
don't stick out or stand out yeah
because I didn't want to be the goofball
and then like have the homies label me
the f word you know so I was like [ __ ] I
better put that [ __ ] away like they're
gonna think of the f word
like a fairy or something yeah [ __ ] a
fairy ass [ __ ] you know yeah
yeah yeah so I was like I better be
[ __ ] hard I got beat down and
dependable even though those things are
completely separate you know yeah it's
actually more psychotic to be funny and
um
it's [ __ ] crazy yeah that was that
was that was both you know yeah and I
think through MMA was when I was like
would mess around and then me and Joe
start messing around even more we're
like oh [ __ ] we're actually both like
way goofier and then we started hanging
out yeah it's so interesting how
um just kind of seeing the evolution of
like how we were to what we thought we
were to now what I mean who knows we
might not even be where we're at like
where we think we should be yet
and maybe in another 10 years we're
gonna look back and damn we really
didn't live our full [ __ ] potential
yeah I feel like I'm gonna have that
actually in 10 years really yeah so when
you're
49
yeah closer to 50. you think you're
gonna look back now and go possibly yeah
I was a [ __ ] butterfly still waiting
to like I think so yeah I think so wow
yeah I think so I'm I just learned so
much every single day I think I'm fully
sprouted
what do you mean I think I am who I am
now I don't think so you don't think you
you don't have any more growing to do
I think I got more capitalizing to do
but I think I am who I am now
um I know I am who I am
but
how do I explain it
I am who I am and I don't see myself
changing like uh like my morals are
always going to be the same you know
um my virtues will still be the same
like obviously I'm not gonna [ __ ] one
day want to start like killing and
stealing and cheating for the sake of
like
for bad intentions I might have to do
that for survival but that's a whole
different thing right motive
um
but I feel like the older I'm gonna get
I think I'm gonna give even lesser [ __ ]
because I just I've been noticing that
pattern the older I become I give less
and less [ __ ] and then you see older
people like in their 60s 70s 80s and
they give no [ __ ] yeah
uh that I barely give any [ __ ] yeah
you're already not giving a lot you
could already tell I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah a lot of [ __ ] and like from this
year to last year I already filled my
[ __ ] meter go way down
like before I'd be so [ __ ] into like
oh my God what I look like right now
like oh my God what are they gonna think
about me what are they gonna say and now
I'm going like who the [ __ ] are they I
don't even care like I really I already
was that way but now more so
you know
um so like I I think I'll look back at
my
40s and be like oh man I still gave way
too many [ __ ] and I was doing [ __ ] I
was doing things for the sake of fox and
I just gave [ __ ] about the wrong things
yeah rather than doing it for yourself
because you didn't really like it yeah
and I don't feel like that has anything
to do with who I am I think it's just or
maybe maybe it does and I think that's
what I'm trying to touch on
you know like that I'm gonna look back
and be like I wasn't there yet yeah
that's why I also feel like I you know a
lot of people they they hit me up and
even like mentorship program and stuff
like people they'll like ask me about um
you know when they first hustle and
they're able to like earn a decent
amount yeah and obviously everyone knows
your goal is to get whatever you earn
and how do I double triple how do I
immediately invest right but then
everyone also has the impulse and the
urge to like can I spend and Splurge a
little bit on myself you know and I
always tell everyone to do it
responsibly though but do it because
once you do it I'm at least for me I'm
the type of person to know where where
that line is and once I've stepped
across it and I know how it feels then I
can go back to hmm do I like it or not
yeah versus if I never do I always have
to urge yeah you know so like let's say
if I started making money if I don't get
the Rollie or whatever
then it's going to keep boiling my mind
I think the next time it's going to be
something else it's gonna be something
and then by the time I do do it it's
gonna go too crazy you know versus I'm
glad I did it and I'm like okay I know
what that feels like okay cool like I
think I got that on my system so even
now like
um after having a Porsche after having
an Audi like this like an R7 I'm like oh
those are pretty nice cars
um but I could already see the
trajectory and I'm like I don't know if
lambo's gonna bring me that much
happiness I don't know if a Ferrari is
gonna bring me that much happiness and
I'm like I just like my truck I think I
think it's so [ __ ] cool you know yeah
I think it's uh it comes from
experiences these are all experiences
that you're talking about right yeah so
the more that we can put ourselves
through different experiences the wiser
we become and then we really know like
who we are what we like what we don't
like what we should pursue what we
shouldn't pursue
because they are they're all experiences
yeah because like I can relate with that
right when I was buying my first things
without looking at the price tag and
then going like oh [ __ ] this is tight
and it is a rite of passage and I'm like
I always dreamed of this moment but then
it was so fleeting that I'm like oh yeah
this isn't me at all but it's an
experience you know but like when it
comes to like now traveling and visiting
a different country and like seeing all
that [ __ ] I'm like oh man this is really
tight sadly now I'm [ __ ] scared of
flying but what happened to that right
yeah I gotta get that [ __ ] it's still
mind-blowing to me for me too because
you used to like roller coasters if you
don't like flying how are you even gonna
fly a roller coaster I don't know maybe
some [ __ ] happened in my equilibrium or
like my ears are [ __ ] the fluid in my
ears all [ __ ] up that [ __ ] 39 man
I don't even care
I don't even care the older I get the
more I like it that's CUNY yeah the
older I get the more I like it you know
what I realized when I was old I was
looking in the mirror yesterday when I
was training and I was like my face
looks young right because that like but
that's deceitful and then I started to
look at my neck skin yeah that shows it
and I was looking at my neck and I was
like oh [ __ ] I think my neck is showing
my age because my face looks young but
the neck don't lie yeah the neck don't I
saw a crease right here you see that
crease yeah I was like damn that's that
[ __ ]
old like when you're in your 40s and
you've been in the sun crease I was like
dude
what are you gonna do about it nothing
the same thing you do about those crusty
ass feet well I just wear socks I wear a
scarf you can't see that [ __ ] I still
look 25 up here I mean you can't hide it
though because after a while those socks
are breaking and they're going what the
[ __ ] hey guess what I'm balling I
thought I'll buy another pair of socks
I thought you're gonna get them fixed
what happened you were fixed you're
[ __ ] crusty ass feet
well
what when I have time to get them fixed
yeah I mean are we gonna have to split
up now and we're gonna have to [ __ ]
dissolve everything because your ass
can't handle well do the pedicure oh is
that what it's called I'll do a pedicure
one of these days we'll do them back in
L.A we'll go to the [ __ ] one of those
Vietnamese spots
get all fixed up do they cut your nails
too yeah everything let's do that
because I'm due for it massage your legs
I'm doing for a nail nail equipment too
that's CUNY we'll go get our feet down
are you down here to feed that oh my god
I've been waiting let's go do it I've
been waiting for that you know scrub
that [ __ ] off me but yeah you're just so
CUNY I didn't know you were that CUNY
where you're like if we're not doing it
together we're not doing it at all where
I'm going hmm well if I built it with
you I'm very CUNY I'm very sentimental
like that you know dang I'm not
sentimental at all nah why [ __ ]
that's the answer to everything [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know why I'm
not sentimental I've never been that way
like I would see people this is I'm
[ __ ] how weird I am but I would see
people like remember you would um date
or whatever and you would keep [ __ ] in a
shoebox I would see that in movies
and then I'm like oh I guess I have to
do this but like I'm after a while I'm
like why do I just have junk I'm never
gonna look at again
that's because you don't look at him I
look at him for what just to like you
know imagine your life in the past is
[ __ ] cool but why do you need to do
that
because it's fun to think about memories
you don't like Memories if you don't
like Memories why you like making them
isn't that weird so like with taika
those are the only ones that I look back
I'm like oh that's so cute but
everything else I'm like
I don't look at those anymore because I
have a wife now but it's fun to look at
your own Journey you know like your own
progress like what was Bart like at five
oh he did this oh oh cool look at my
watch like I have a watch in there I see
and then you're like oh remember that
yeah I used to wear this or whatever
it's almost like a conversation you have
with yourself that's CUNY you know yeah
I never I remember like that that
relationship you had when you're like uh
whatever the 15 oh I've already thinking
you know I wonder where that comes from
then I'm like me
and it's not [ __ ] dude I wasn't gonna
say that
you ever know where it comes from where
I'm like maybe I just didn't grow up
girl like no memories not really like
the cool thing even though she doesn't
like memories that much um the cool
thing is each one of the kids had a
photo album yeah so like I can look back
and be like oh that's how my sister
whatever was raised but I never cared to
look at my own
I was just like interested with what
their problem memory sucks you don't
ever review the last chapter yeah maybe
see do they suck your memory still it's
the worst even now even worser no really
yeah you didn't have the worst memory in
the world come on you can't even
remember [ __ ] that [ __ ] happened I
told you I was gonna get a haircut two
days ago about yesterday you know like
what why it's not remembering I think of
my I think I'm thinking about a bunch of
[ __ ] all at once I mean you call it what
you want but your memory sucks ass nah I
don't think it was a memory thing
because if we would have been like hey
okay maybe it does suck maybe it does
suck but yeah I just didn't know you
were that CUNY I didn't know you were
that sentimental
how do you how do you feel knowing that
I'm I'm not
it's fine I think everyone's everyone's
different you know I don't think
everyone has to be the same but that's
just how I process it so like let's say
if uh we do break up and you want to
continue whatever crazy entity we got
going on I'm like okay that's on you
what about get close
I want to pursue get
yeah but find another co-hosts I might
find another co-host really yeah
yeah but this one would be kind of weird
see yeah because we're talking about
like pretty intimate things yeah it's
things that we have views on or we like
uh experience together you know yeah I
don't know though I'd be like I would
have a homey conversation with you like
it wouldn't be romantic but I would be
bringing up romantic memories yeah but I
don't think I'd be like
like I'd rather just have a fresh start
you know I'd rather be [ __ ] chopping
Lumber or something
God damn that's not even a fresh start
that's just like forget that life
existed that's me that's how I am have
you done that with other stuff a lot of
stuff like what what's your Fresh Start
when's the last time I played drums I
used to identify as a drummer what
happened why didn't you do that
I [ __ ] got kicked out of school
oh and that was your thing like um so
growing up
um I was in band in fifth grade sixth
grade seventh grade I really like drums
that was like my set and before that I
was kung fu boy threw that away now I'm
like drummer guy I really like playing
drums
um and freshman year
um when you go to a school that's a
really really good drum line you have to
audition for every step and it's not
there's a hierarchy so there's symbols
there's uh if you're above symbols is
the bass drum and there's five of those
guys and then above that is Tenors and
then when you're really good you play
snare
and snare is usually all Juniors and
seniors
and so when you get thrown into a band
you immediately go to the pit the pit is
like you're playing like xylophones and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] hitting the cowbell
whatever
um my freshman year two symbol spots
open up a ton of freshmen auditioned me
and his other freshmen are the only one
to become symbols so that already shows
we're the best of the freshmen next year
two snare spots open up as a sophomore
but me and that same cat we [ __ ] both
got the snare position and I was
probably one of the best drummers
at the time
and then when I got kicked out of school
I go to marqueppel and at that time I
show up I'm like yo I went to the band
practice I'm like yo this is the band
and I'm like it's not what I'm used to
what I'm used to is you have one band
director maybe two assistant band
directors you have a horn technician you
have a woodwind technician
um you go to the drum line you have a
drum instructor damn you guys had money
you had like snares one guy yeah you got
snare technician like you have like all
set it's like it's like you know when
you go to uh some college [ __ ] when you
go to a good college football team you
got offensive coach defensive coach
strength and conditioning coach all
different right it's just different if
you're going to have the same thing if
you've got a shitty football team you
have one coach that literally does
everything right ours was like hooked up
like that because we were really good
band and Drumline when I came to Kepler
I'm like bro to be honest I can't be
playing for you guys this is like oh my
bro
so I ended up not doing it I gave that
up and then it was just like time for a
new life
so that's what happened
and now look at you what I don't play
drums no more that's correct so for me
it's easier to just go you know what
like whatever feelings and whatever I
had so just give us I was just like
let's just give up
just gave it up yeah it's give it up
just switch your rooski you know
[ __ ]
that's crazy to me if I was [ __ ] good
at some [ __ ] then I'd be like now I'm
pursuing it if I loved it as much as it
sounds like you my parents hated that I
loved it too so there's just so many
things going against me you know oh
I mean like when I was a sophomore in
high school
before I got kicked out of school I
literally showed my mom hey Berkeley
School of Music I think I can go there
where John Mayer win we're [ __ ] uh
I don't think John Legend oh he didn't
um who's the other cat that [ __ ] up
Jason Mraz like there's a lot of people
that went there you know and I was like
I think I could go there just be pretty
cool really develop myself anyway and
then
um she's like no why would you go there
that's such a weird because like she saw
that the minimum GPA was 2.0
and she said why would you go this
[ __ ] that's such a minimum GPA I'm
like yeah because they care about your
portfolio they just want you know you
can do the Bare Bones academics but they
want to see like what you submit because
it's a School of Art
so now you want to go to school where
the minimum GP is at least like three
point whatever you know so I was like
what the [ __ ]
so I just too many people didn't believe
in me
yeah it's easy to let it go yeah for
sure yeah so I I for me it's just way
easy to just go Switcheroo what's the
new thing and not build a new life based
off the new thing damn
splitting up anytime soon so we're
pretty solid you sure I'm pretty sure
are you sure yeah I'm pretty sure I love
you
you're pretty sure all right so am I so
we're good for now
we're good and we're we're we're here
we've arrived at the end anything else
you want to add you [ __ ] sentimental
[ __ ] nope all right so uh peace out
from this cold-hearted [ __ ] uh and I
will see you next week
okay bye